so good to connect with you because all
of our emotions are really high watching
the show and I can't even imagine how
you're feeling right now what was the
experience like for you to be on the
show now that you're out of it yeah uh
you know when I left filming for the
show I felt like I hadn't turned over
every stone I felt like I had done what
I went there to do which was invest
myself in these relationships and figure
out if there was anything there for me
of course watching it back with the
information that America has while
they're watching I am like what were you
thinking why would you make those
decisions why would you say those things
but hindsight is always 20/20 and I'm
fortunately living with like with a lot
of regret
yeah and when you think about it and I
think a lot of people forget this part
is that the show was made for you to
find that person to build that chemistry
finding that definitive relationship
when you were there when did you realize
that you wanted to test the waters with
Brandon um I never gave ranan up after
that first kiss honestly like we had the
first kiss of the entire yeah her Snyder
and I kind of always had him in the back
of my mind and obviously that was
abundantly clear throughout the season
so I was never willing to give that up
because I didn't know what that meant I
didn't know whether that meant that was
the substantial relationship that I
should be here for suing and it's very
difficult when you have a torn heart to
pour yourself into either relationship
yeah yeah yeah
was there something missing with
Sheridan that you're trying to find a
Brandon you know Brandon and I some of
the things that you don't get to see are
the other conversations that I have yeah
and which was it was clear to me when
Sheridan left and said she's falling
into a pattern she's falling for the bad
guys he knew that was my pattern cuz we
discussed my dating history and Brandon
and I had this very like witty banter we
just had that like thing where we would
feed off of each other and we would
laugh as seriusly and Sheridan and I had
the more deeper intimate connection so
they were just they were different and I
don't know that one is better than the
other when you're trying to figure
something out that early on in the
dating process mm-hmm I talked to
Sheridan yesterday a-and I know you guys
we're trying to connect one way or
another and you guys really haven't had
a chance to have a discussion for you is
it more of trying to figure out if you
can have a relationship with him or is
it more to have peace with it and just
or is it to apologize to him it's a
combination I have apologized to him so
I feel like I did that aspect of it
justice you know like I I think when you
grovel it actually just sounds like
you're not actually sincere about the
apology I am sincere about the apology
I've made my apology I think after the
show shared and I were exploring a
relationship and which felt very
different in the real world and felt
actually better than on the show when
you have all these forces working there
so you have talked to him after the last
episode aired
yeah actually had not not after the last
episode aired so we have even seen
between filming and airing and then we
have not really spoken since episode two
and that's been really difficult for me
I hope that we can connect again whether
that's for closure or exploring
something I don't know I don't begin to
imagine knowing and I don't know that he
knows either so it's like yeah I do hope
that there is a moment for some closure
because I think we owe that to each
other we did go through this experience
together should he forgive the situation
you know I think about it in terms of
like the dating life in my real in the
real world and I wish that men were as
honest with me that early on you know
like let's take this into the real world
we knew each other for two weeks you
know like I would never start to date
someone seriously in two weeks so I was
kind of like resisting the whole like
concept of the show really in my like
spiraling and so yeah I do think that
what happened is worthy of forgiveness
because I was open it was painful and
I'm sure watching it back was even more
painful but I truthfully at the end of
the day don't believe I you know I
didn't cheat on him you know like it's
when you think of like the ultimate
wrongs of relationships I don't think I
committed one of those things
so I am hopeful that forgiveness is on
the other side of this and I love the
way you said that because you've been
getting a lot of backlash on social
media after what happened and he stepped
up for you and said you know this
bullying is not allowed this is not you
weren't there with the situation how are
you feeling have you read some of the
comments and have you seen them yeah
it's hard not to see them because I do
want to acknowledge the people that have
come to rally around me and support me
so inevitably I see date I think it's
sad that we feel it's okay to judge
someone based on a reality TV show it
makes me sad that people think that
that's all there is to me because it's
just simply not the truth and it's been
a very dark time in my life I have to
admit and the bullying has crossed a
line to the point where people are
telling suggesting I kill myself
and it just seems honestly it seems
ludicrous it just seems so ridiculous to
me and I'm trying to put that in
perspective and say those people are
clearly hurting to be sending out such
hatred my way yeah and I wish them the
best and I hope that if you don't like
me just keep walking
yeah are you avoiding social media right
now because it seems like affecting you
a fair amount right now
yeah I'm limiting my time I also am
embracing the fact that like yeah I went
on a reality TV show you can judge my
decisions on that reality TV show that's
time but I'm not going to cower because
some of you don't like me and that's
always been my mentality in life I am a
fighter
I've fought hard battles all my life a
few internet trolls aren't that big of a
deal would you want to do reality TV
again have probably been absolutely not
[Music]
fascinating process I wouldn't rule it
out I think you know I think my biggest
lesson throughout all of this is that my
self-worth is actually not where I need
it to be it's why I chase after men like
Brandon it's it's why that is a pattern
for me and I am taking this time to look
myself in the mirror and say you deserve
you deserve more you deserve to be
treated better and you deserve to be
loved by you and I think if I were to be
in that place and that state of mind I
could say yes to another show but who
knows what the future holds do you turn
to music when you're feeling a little
bit daily out yeah are you creating
music right now I am I'm writing
non-stop initially I think I shut down
just so much emotionally from the hate
and also just I wasn't expecting it to
play back this way to be quite honest
with you it didn't feel that way to me
you know like you're being such an
abbreviated version of what happened so
it was initially hard I didn't have any
creative juices flowing just purely
because I was so depressed but I am now
on the other side of that I'm on the
upswing of just looking at this as
another challenge to overcome